all my heroes are going down  arnold schwarzenegger another great man  that dude should be unloading trucks in  transylvania  that should be that should have been the  height of his success  but because he's a great man he had the  balls to move to america  became famous for lifting weights i lift  weights nobody gives a [ __ ]  he lifts weights  becomes super famous  did he rest on his laurels no next  challenge i'm gonna become an actor  despite the fact that nobody can really  understand me  against all odds he starts making movies  get down there's a bomb gets out of  there  becomes one of the biggest blockbuster  stars of all time  what are you gonna do next arnie i think  amanda kennedy there's no [ __ ] way  you can do that bam he does it  cherry on top i'm running for governor  of a state i can't even pronounce and he  wins the election